President Trump has been accused of
trying to lure a German pharmaceutical
company working on a corona virus
vaccine to the US a German newspaper
says that Trump offered large amounts of
money to secure cure VAX
vaccine exclusively for the US German
authorities insist that no country
should have a monopoly that is offering
its own financial incentives for the
vaccine to stay in the country well Rick
Bruckner is a political analyst and
joins us now live via Skype from Dresden
in Germany Ulrich good to have you with
us many people watching will never have
heard of cure vac until this moment what
sort of company is it well it's one of
those biotech companies that start
lately to focus on something that is
important in days like the corona virus
this has received a large investment
from the Melinda and Bill Gates
Foundation from the German government
but also from the US Department of
Defense to find a groundbreaking
solution for the corona virus so what's
alleged to have happened here well the
way it is portrayed in the media and
also in the press conferences with
leading members of the German government
is sort of a stereotypical narrative
between Germany as a multilateral
cosmopolitan globalist country that is
committed to solidarity of mankind and a
nationalist
who looks at it from a capitalist point
of view to make medication exclusive to
the American people in the typical way
of America first ok so what's been the
reaction to this there in Germany both
from the government and from Kiev acts
investors well a leading investor who
owns 80% of the company is one of the
founders of the software giant SAV in
the south of Germany and he also owns a
soccer team and
was portrayed lately as an evil
capitalist who's only interested in
making money now that you would happen
to list vetoed the transfer of the
company from Germany to the United
States because he believes that this is
something that is so important that
everyone in the world should benefit
from the research in this company and
the German government also invested
three digits of millions in this
groundbreaking technology and everyone
is hoping that during this year they
will find a solution and that's a nation
for the correcting errors Oh Rick good
talk to you many thanks indeed for being
with us
Ulrich Brooke today live via Skype from
Dresden